رغم انتاجها للنفط تتجه ايران الى الوقود
الروسي محكومه بطلاق مصالح مع الحليفه
موسكو لا سيما في العقوبات المفروضه على
البلدين والاستهلاك الذي فاق ما تنتجه من
الوقود المحلي خصوصا في اقاليمها الشماليه
تقول مصادر وبيانات الصادرات ان روسيا
بدات في نقل الوقود الى ايران عبر السكك
الحديديه للمره الاولى في وقت سابق هذا
العام بعدما عزف المشترون التقليديون عن
التجاره مع موسكو اذا زودت موسكو طهران
بما يصل الى 30 الف طن من البنزين والديزل
في فبراير ومارس بحسب المصادر فان الشركات
النفط الروسيه حاليا بدات في تصدير الديزل
والبنزين الى ايران عن طريق السكك
الحديديه والسبب ان الشحن البحري يخضع
لاسعار شحن عاليه ولسقف للاسعار تفرضه دول
مجموعه السبعه النفط الروسي يصل ايران عبر
السكك الحديديه مرورا بكل من قزاخستان
وتركمان